why are you the way that you are
honestly every time i try to do
something fun or exciting
you make it not that way
i hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
you give up never
get out of face me like a man i am a man
i'm a bigger man than you'll ever be i
would never sleep with another man's
you're not a man you don't know how to
take care of her
all you do is dress fancy and sing
what does that mean you can't even
protect her protect her from what bears
you idiot when's the last time you saw
damn baron scranton last year idiot
dwight
are your legs broken no my right one's
falling asleep a little bit andy you all
right go away tuna i'm winning this yeah
back off this isn't your fight oh how
much is this going to cost oh
what trust fond will take care of that
what did you say i'm sorry i couldn't
hear you i see
what you stupid idiot
you're like a bit you're like a
sasquatch you live in
the strongest animal on the planet so
fine call me a sasquatch i don't get it
how could she be sleeping with you this
whole time only sleep with me twice
what what
she's sleeping with you
i'm gonna fail today
she said she was only sleeping with me
this here is a radon test kit okay i'll
be putting them everywhere and
please don't throw these out
this is a radon test kit
please don't throw these out
see them all over the office toby has
been leaving radon kits everywhere like
he owns the place
the first time i threw mine away i
thought it was an ant trap
but i figured i'd rather live with anson
with his creepy little disk
the second time
i thought it was one of those you know
the things you turn over and a moose
like a cow thing but upon closer
examination it was another ant trap so i
threw it away and the third time
i did it out of spite
come on michael you're you're
interrupting you're kidding me god you
say rayon is silent but deadly and then
you expect me not to make farting noises
with my mouth what is this please sit
down you know what we're not gonna die
of radon we're gonna die of boredom yeah
right
and if i had a gun with two bullets and
i was in a room with hitler bin laden
and toby i would shoot toby
twice no
that's not okay you're all right really
funny and then you went too far i would
kill bin laden and then toby no that's
still
okay geniuses how would you do it curve
the bullet like in my favorite james
mcavoy film i
what all that does is help you shoot
around things which has been live is
there a curtain rod in the room i don't
know how about make believe land has
anything you want stanley please this is
serious
is this the thing where they use an
icicle so there's no evidence yes we
stabbed toby through the hardwood high
school two bullet thing is a red herring
here's how you do it you line them all
up you take one bullet shoot them all
through the throat at the same time
watch this phyllis you're hitler come up
here toby you're toby andy you're bin
laden line up uh i don't want her to
throats together toby just do it toby
come on god
ready one bullet and
boom
boom
hey what's going on you guys
yeah three musket queers
mean but good
so todd this must be nice for you
getting off the road you get to spend
some time with your daughter i don't
know i love her and all but she turned
into a [ __ ] mostly she's great but some
days she acts like her mom
well some girls go through a phase yeah
your life is so insane
you should write a book since when did
you learn how to read i do know how to
read though yeah you know how to read a
menu
[Music]
i'm
he's right i mean i could lose some
weight kevin
in sumo culture you'd be considered a
promising up-and-comer
now folks by special request we're gonna
take it a little old school
there is a former trebler in this room
who it's mr andy bernard
[Applause]
no do not sing that do not he reminded
us today of how much he means to us
and we certainly seem to mean a lot to
him
so without any further ado here's an old
treble classic
what the hell is broccoli rob doing here
she said you wanted to hear faith that's
broccoli rob's signature song oh but i
need some time off that's my signature
song
i really didn't know that man i just
thought you wanted to hear it
russell i'm dressed like george michael
i thought you were adam lambert
the more i hear about all this acapella
drama the more i think it's kind of
pathetic
but when you're with someone you put up
with the stuff that makes you lose
respect for them and that is love
aaron
there's a call for you on line one
who is it
he says salvation no last name
yeah hello you once put me on a list of
the losers in the office well this loser
just got your biggest client to give him
all their business
so hire me back that business is yours
don't and i will find another buyer
you're blackmailing me
it's just business
well
i will not be blackmailed by some
ineffectual privileged defeat soft penis
debutant you want to start a street
fight with me bring it on but you're
going to be surprised by how ugly it
gets you don't even know my real name
i'm the lizard king
so
how are you awesome i am dating a lot of
guys good a lot black guys mostly
kelly what
i want you to tell me that you care
about me that is what i want kelly i'm
your boss now okay you can't keep
talking to me like i'm your boyfriend oh
big strong man fancy new whatever i
don't think you ever cared about me i
never cared about you six months ago
karen filippelli sent me an email asked
me out i said no because i was committed
to our relationship well i hope you're
still committed because i'm pregnant
and guess what buddy i am keeping it
okay
okay do you feel prepared to help me
raise a baby
i can't talk about this right now okay
after work we'll go out to dinner we'll
talk about it then okay
we have a date
well if he's not gonna make it at least
we should go ahead and
eat the cake
yeah
i for one love the corners
why did i just do that
it's not even that good
i don't even look i don't even want it
i had cake for lunch
no you know what i've been good i
deserve this
what am i doing come on